la cour d'appel a décidé de la
révocation du placement sous bracelet
électronique
il faut savoir que lorsqu'on est
condamné on peut obtenir une espèce de
faveur de la part de la justice
c'est la justice qui permet d'être placé
sous bracelet électronique et qui permet
d'effectuer une peine chez soi avec un
dispositif électronique avec des heures
de sortie avec un une un lieu de sortie
etc et
il se trouve que les balkany n'ont pas
respecté ses obligations la et qu'en
tant que par conséquent le ministère
public a demandé la révocation d'accord
alors et il ya plein de gens qui disent
qu'ils sont pas dangereux qui devrait
pas qui pourrait rester avec leurs
brasseries et oignies qu'est ce que vous
répondez à sa manie de la justice et
sont obligés de mansart d'un point du
point de vue du droit cette décision est
tout à fait normal c'est à dire que le
ministère public a parfaitement le droit
de décider cette révocation et de décès
de la mettre à exécution elle n'a pas
encore été mais elle pourra très bien
l'être dans les prochains jours après il
faudra déterminer si du côté de la santé
des balkany cette décision est justifiée
ou pas et si on va les plats sont encore
souvent coiffée avec alors justement
d'en parler dans un instant la santé des
balkany puisque le message inquiétant
d'isabelle balkany sur les réseaux cet
après midi isabelle a posté un message
très important sur la photo on peut lire
il est temps que c est temps que ça
s'arrête jamais juste dormir dormir
épuisée par l'âge le mien la haine des
autres l'angoissent pour l'homme de ma
vie la blessure inguérissable du gommage
de ce que j'ai pu faire de positif trois
petits points merci à ceux qui m'ont
fait le bonheur de mai mais bien mes
amours à quatre pattes et il est temps
que ça s'arrête avec ce message
gilles verdez c'est très inquiétant
parce que l avait déjà fait une
tentative de suicide donc là patrick
balkany a appelé le samu immédiatement
qui est intervenue elle a été
hospitalisée
c'est vrai qu'on a peur pour elle l'état
est assez grave alors ce qui s'est passé
c'est que eux crient vraiment à
l'injustice c'est vrai que ça a sonné
sans foi mais eux disent pourquoi il
montre bracelet sonne parce que quand on
va chercher le courrier la propriété est
grande quand on va au portail quand on
va à l'annexé voir nos petits-enfants ça
sonne mais la justice répond arrêtez de
vous moquer de nous on vous a vue à
levallois vous dites que vous avez été
pris dans des embouteillages et que vous
pourriez pas être de retour à la bonne
heure c et donc les juges en ont eu
marre et ils ont dit plus que c'est
comme ça et bien on révoque le bracelet
électronique était un aménagement vous
allez aller en prison voilà alors à la
base comme on l'a dit avec le rallye
s'il devait porter un bracelet
électronique s'il savait s'il avait
respecté les conditions il serait resté
en liberté enfin oui c'est ça alors là
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de manquements il ya plus
d'une centaine de manquements sont les
manquements les plus importants plus
sales alors visiblement patrick balkany
aurait été vu à un match de basket
il peut y avoir des dysfonctionnements
aussi un mois j'ai des clients pour
lesquels on a des dysfonctionnements de
basse et électroniques est ce vrai que
des fois ça sonne donc la personne est
chez elle donc il va falloir déterminer
si ce sont les dysfonctionnements aussi
vraiment ils n'ont pas respecté mais une
centaine de dysfonctionnement c'est
quand même beaucoup ce qui justifie
cette révocation est au moins de mars
c'est au moins de mars c'était fini
c'est ça qu'ils disent ils disent mais
pourquoi on aurait eu tant lentement
puisque dans un mois vous pouvez être en
liberté conditionnelle mais sans
bracelet saissac répondait pas ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec la décision de
la justice thierry khayat vous habitez
levallois oui tout à fait vous vous
révolte cette décision oui parce que si
vous voulez moi je connais les balkany
je les vois je les ai vus pendant
longtemps et c'est des personnes qui
sont bon d'abord très âgées je pense que
ils ont été en haut de la fiche ils ont
été pour moi ils ont été humiliés ils
ont été ils ont été punis par la
situation de prison qu'ils ont vécu on
les a traînés dans la boue je pense
qu'ils ont payé leur dette par rapport à
leur statut je pense que par rapport à
ce qu'ils ont fait dans leur vie par
pour la ville de levallois qui est une
ville exemplaire et moi je suis pas
stripe à la mairie de levallois je suis
tu fais pas de woodside rap à la mairie
de valence je suis pas de juin je suis
jamais fait de politique donc je suis un
vrai levalloisien je sais qu'ils sont
très proches de leurs administrés et
j'ai été outré de la manière dont six
sont traités
salavaux xixe à l'orage y est on aurait
pu les laisser avec le brass électrique
valérie vous mettre d'accord je
comprends la détresse je comprends ce
sentiment peut-être d'injustice mais on
n'est pas là pour juger sur le fond
simplement ils sont des justiciables
comme les autres et il y a il y a des
gens qui vieillissent en prison il ya
des gens qui ont 70 74 62 ou 80 ans qui
sont en prison donc je peux je pense que
l'opinion publique ne comprendrait pas
en disant mais pourquoi eux et pas et
pas nous pourquoi et dont deux citoyens
des citoyens qui eux
bénéficieraient de dalida de mansuétude
alors que d'autres non benjamin vous
n'êtes pas d'accord moi non parce que
effectivement more heroes favier en
prison car on en a parlé ici ça me
paraît normal dans leur cas où ils ont
été punis alors je crois pris tout ce
qu'ils avaient comme bien il aurait été
largement punis et c'est vrai que l'on
libère souvent les gens pour raisons de
santé on sait très bien que patrick est
pas du tout on s'en rend bonne santé
mais quand sa femme ça fait la deuxième
fois qu'elle tente de mettre fin à ses
jours donc au bout d'un moment non alors
que eux ne se sont pas un danger pour la
société ils font mal appris à personne
c'est pas mal a donc effectivement ils
ont ils ont fait des bêtises il ya une
il ya eu un jugement et ont plus rien à
ce sera l'europe mais non mais si on a
alors en fait on va les remettre en
prison parce qu'il embrasse les a sonné
excuse moi
ils ont été condamnés voilà dans leur
malheur ils ont une chose comme
incroyable c'est qu'ils sont dans une
propriété gigantesque ce sont des
justiciables comme tout le monde voilà
il y avait il des verts bracelet
électronique il devait voilà avant des
obligations il ya eu 100 ans en temps
utile des musiciens depuis le début aura
non se considère comme d'ajouter ma part
ne sont pas
cassés tout le monde ne vont pas en
prison monsieur je suis j'ai vu hier il
ya quelques jours un monsieur qui cette
cata passer un fou un un conducteur de
bus et népal en paix sont pas prêt alors
monsieur ils sont parents présents
monsieur il a
laissé pendant 60
ans elle a déjà demandé c'est
bien quand je vais chercher quatre mois
et ceux qui sont comme tout le monde ne
sont pas traités comme justement comme
il le faut c'est là le problème ce
qu'ils ont c'est cyril parlais tout à
l'heure de donneurs de la justice et
bien écoutez moi il ne faut pas être des
déserts ne sais pas c'est pas au premier
manquement qu'on leur vraie belle 6e
place